Here the only value that makes those statements true is positive one. That's
amazing work if you got this one correct. It was tough. First, we'll square
both sides of the equation to get 4x squared plus 4x plus 1 equaled to 5x plus
4. Next we want to get a quadratic on one side of the equation, and the other
side equal to zero. So we can subtract 5x from both sides, and subtract 4 from
both sides. We'll have 0 on the right and this quadratic on the left. Next, we
use factoring by grouping to get 4x plus 3 times x minus 1 equals 0. Once we
have our factors of 4x plus 3 and x minus 1, we set each of those equal to 0.
Then, we can solve for x, so x equals negative 3 4ths. Or x equals positive 1.
And like all of our radical equations from before, we need to check each of
these solutions in the original equation. When I plug in x equals 1, I get 3
equals 3. So, yes, this will be part of our solution set. For x equals negative
3 4's, we wind up with a solution that doesn't check. We know 2 times negative
3 4ths is negative 3 half, since we can cancel the common factor of 2, in the
numerator and denominator. Here we'll just multiply 5 times negative 3 4ths to
get negative 15 4ths. We change 4 into 16 4ths so we can add these two
fractions together. This gives us a positive 1 4th underneath our radical. W
stake the radical of the numerator and the denominator to get 1 half since the
square root of 1 is 1 and the square root of 4 is 2. On the left side I changed
tho simperer fraction to a mice dumber. Negative 1 and 1 half. We know negative
1 and positive 1 sum to 0, so we're left with negative 1 half. These two
statements are not true, so we cannot include this as part of our solution set,
it's out. This is why our solution set is only positive 1.